The joe rogan experience.
Cause you're saying that's the number one negative,
all this social stuff.
I mean,
I feel like the,
the most hilarious thing is that Kim Jong,
Ooh,
actually wants to talk to him.
I was like,
this guy is so crazy.
Maybe.
Maybe I'll just talk to them.
I mean like what do you want to do?
Nobody,
nobody else wanted to have meetings with that guy.
Right.
He's wanted to talk to a president for the longest time and the,
they were dark to hit,
right.
Because they don't want to give them that good photo opportunity.
At the very least.
That's hilarious.
They're worried about their Facebook page.
Would we witness that if they talked,
fuck yeah,
we would witness it and Trump would tower over them.
It would be so creepy.
Trump's a big guy and you see what happens.
When,
have you ever seen pictures of him with,
um,
Dez Robin?
Do you ever see pictures of Kim Jong Min?
I'm good dude.
Kim Jong,
Ooh,
uh,
is a huge basketball fan apparently and loves Dennis Rodman.
Dennis Rodman goes to North Korea parties,
right?
Right.
Dennis Rodman.
Like if Trump was smart,
I know Trump hired Amarosa Trump should definitely hire Dennis Rodman.
Fucking 100%.
Like 100%.
Say Dennis Rodman.
Please.
Would you be my emissary?
I'll look at that.
We got big dance.
Rodman is,
that's a large fellow and he's not even big compared to like a really big guy.
Right?
Like Lebron.
What if he's pretty big?
What's his name?
King a King Jong.
What?
Kim Jong.
Ooh.
They still can't say get a picture of King Jong.
Kim Jong with Dennis Rodman.
What if you were like,
Eh,
you think it'd be bad if he went like foot high platforms?
They're the rd,
but he denied it.
Yeah,
he probably would.
And he had long pants trying to cover them while he's Korean.
Well,
he's North Korean.
Uh,
there's some Korean folks that are pretty big.
Um,
I remember,
um,
when I was a kid,
the kid who won the heavyweight,
a national title is named Jimmy Kim.
He was a big Korean kid,
big heavyweight kid.
It was really good.
Six foot five.
So I don't know how big Kim Jong Un is,
but I bet he looks tiny compared to Dennis Rodman two foot three.
I just looked it up on my phone.
Wow.
That was quick.
I think it would be a weird meeting,
but it might actually be okay.
It might be good.
This people gotta something's gotta break over there like what they're doing.
It's just insane the way they keep those people essentially hostage.
There's no food that people that have escaped if had horrible fucking parasites
in their body and like,
see,
I feel bad.
I,
I don't know.
Like,
so guys escaped and got shot at on the border.
Fascinating footage.
You're saying they keep them hostage.
Who are you talking about?
The people of North Korea,
they're essentially held hostage.
I mean they're,
they're the,
they're trapped by dear leader.
You know what they have to do?
Like if,
when,
when the dad died,
these people were all weeping in the street and they had a weep like outwardly,
loudly,
as long as they could do it.
And if you stopped weeping early,
you'd be punished.
And people who they felt weren't weeping enough.
Got Six months in jail.
It's a crazy place and everyone turns on everyone,
everyone,
rats,
everyone else out on everything they do.
You're supposed to meet together.
You go in front of this,
these people and you rat each other out for all the different things you do.
Michael Mouse has a great book about it.
Is it called dear reader?
Is that the name of his book?
Dear leader or dear reader,
why do I feel it's dear reader?
He's a funny guy.
Michael Mouse.
But um,
North Korea.
Do you ever hear something you're like,
I should know that I should know it too.
That's one of the way you do things about this podcast is just being able to
talk to screen.
It is dear reader.
Yeah.
Um,
being able to talk to people on this podcast and you know,
get like a little quick three hour crash course and what the fuck's going on in
North Korea.
So Michael was a amazing for that.
And you know who else was Henry Rollins was Henry Rollins went over there as a
fucking a tourist and wandered around over there.
That guy's an animal.
Okay.